the anti-government demonstrators have
been calling this d-day for a week and
they're promising it's just the start as
they formed up to march the security
forces moved in the first volleys of
teargas
zipping past and into the crowd the day
used to this they flow them back when
they can
[Applause]
the soon cleared out with more National
Guard were coming
the first country's tear gas and then a
National Guard arrived or they're
carrying shotguns cause this chaos
people running in all sorts of different
directions they're coming from all over
the place
it's very very tense now there's a
motorbike sneered pandemonium broke out
as people tried to flee
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this was a mad scramble to find some
type of safety we were pushed along with
the crowds through the barricades
hundreds heading to the safety of a
Cathedral
there was no time to stop
Russians go to church
the armed motorbike teams cleared their
way through the barricades hunting down
the protesters and coming towards us
there was no escape
[Music]
as they passed one open fire you're
right
hitting our Venezuelan producer
with our hands in the air and press
identity clearly visible there is no
excuse for this this confrontation it's
very violent national card came past us
very very intimidating we had to put our
hands in the air
we're still fired that's a producer's
been hitting the arm as he said it's
happen before it happened again I was
very brave
they really are hardcore playing for
keeps they're going to suppress this
demonstration at any cost the violence
on both sides is escalating as well as
the bight teams headed towards another
group of protesters they were hit by a
roadside bomb
the army is now being sent to the street
the numbers of people being killed here
continues to rise neither side is
prepared to back down
incredibly it's likely to get even worse
still Ramsey Sky News Caracas